the holiday season less merry and bright
as covid 19
continues to hammer the u.s as new
strains emerge overseas
joining us now admiral brett juwah a
member of the white house coronavirus
task force
admiral welcome to fox news sunday
great to be here thank you for having me
on tsa checkpoint travel numbers reveal
more than one million per day
traveling leading up to christmas
despite those coveted warnings
do you expect a spike in new cases as a
result sir
well it really depends on what the
travelers do when they get where they're
going we know the actual
physical act of traveling in airplanes
for example can be quite safe because of
the air purification systems
what we really worry about is the
mingling of different bubbles once you
get to your destination
over thanksgiving we saw a mixed picture
in the midwest and in the northern
plains
cases continued to go down despite the
travel which meant that people really
did the kinds of things we talked to
them about like wearing a mask and
limiting your gathering so we really
have to wait and see
i really encourage people to follow the
cdc guidelines
make your family gathering small safe
protect the elderly and we can get
through this
there are concerns about a new variant
or mutations of the virus in places like
the united kingdom japan
even canada ontario's chief medical
officer announced saturday
that they had confirmed two cases there
considering global travel do you think
this new strain
is now here in the united states
well we don't know if it's here or not
we would say that there's certainly a
possibility that it's here already
because of global travel and it's in so
many countries now let me tell you what
we know about the strain
um it is uh number one it is not any
more serious than the normal strains of
covid
however it does appear to be more
transmissible
there's not direct evidence of that but
there's lots of suggestive evidence
but again you can still protect yourself
by the mitigation measures
and we have no evidence to suggest nor
do we believe
that this vaccine that the vaccine would
not be effective in other words we do
believe the vaccine
will be effective against this variant
so that's why we're
you know so excited and still very
enthusiastic about the vaccine program
which is being rolled out on time on
schedule
with almost 15 and a half million doses
being distributed
by this week upcoming the united states
is requiring negative tests from
travelers coming from the united kingdom
do we need that elsewhere is that enough
at this point
so i think what's often uh not talked
about
is since march there's been a very
substantial travel restriction on uk
and a variety of countries from from
europe so since march
we have had a decrease of 90 to 95
percent
of travelers coming from the uk which is
our first line of defense
which other countries did not have the
added testing
puts an extra layer and that's very
important there's no perfect silver
bullet but a test three days before
now the cdc can't order testing once
you're in states
after that but we would certainly
encourage states to have
quarantine orders or to have testing
once these travelers
arise so 95 decrease already
the extra testing puts another barrier
and the states could also impose things
so i think we're going to be pretty safe
with these as again we roll out vaccines
which are going to be highly effective
against all the strains that are out
there to those coveted vaccines we've
seen first responders some high profile
politicians
rolling up their sleeves who's next in
line to receive the shots
well in the first wave it is really been
our health care workers and those in
nursing homes
the next wave is going to be different
by state the general recommendations are
those over 75
and certain front line workers but it's
going to vary state by state
let me talk about governor abbott in
texas he really is going to prioritize
anyone over 65 because those are the
people who go to the hospitals
it's not the front line 24 year old
worker who is at low risk of getting the
infection
and had very very low risk of getting
serious results from that
but over 65 yes that's who's in the
hospital
and certain other people like cancer
patients or people with sickle cell
disease
governor desantis in florida is
prioritizing everyone over 70.
so i think you're going to see
variability and i think that variability
is critically important because as the
hospitals fill up
the first priority really needs to be to
save lives and to reduce the burden on
hospitals
you're seeing that in texas and florida
and you will probably see that in many
other states interesting okay so how
important is it
for president trump to receive the
vaccine in terms of building that
critical public confidence
well i i of course think that the
president
should get a vaccine at the right time
75 million people voted for him
uh he has devout followers and i think
it would set an example
i i would say that there is a medical
reason and i don't know i'm not his
physician so i don't know exactly right
but he did receive monoclonal antibodies
within the last couple of months
um and there is uh sort of uh you know
guidance about waiting 60 to 90 days
after a monoclonal antibody because it
could interfere with the
with the actual vaccine but of course
president trump for his own protection
and to set an example for the 75 million
people who voted for him
i think it's great idea currently the
emergency authorization is for people at
least 16
and older what about younger children
isn't that
important in terms of getting them back
to school
well we all as a pediatrician we
certainly want to
have the data to show that it's safe and
effective in children we don't have that
yet
that is coming though 16 and above for
one vaccine 18 and above
for the modern vaccine but i think it's
very important for listeners to
understand
that getting children back to school
right now is safe now
there's data upon data upon data that
children could go back to school
safely in person there was a recent
study in the mmwr that said of all the
places
children are likely to turn positive
school is not one of them
so it is safe and very important to get
children back in school
even before they are vaccinated now with
the community rates going down we hope
after the holidays because we're seeing
that trend right now
and with vaccines it'll be even safer
because there'll be less spread in the
community but
children do not need a vaccine to go
back to school safely
it's vital for their health to get them
back physically present as soon as
possible
what about their teachers should they be
higher on the priority list in terms of
vaccinations with
millions of american parents worried
their children are not learning in
online school
well they're probably going to be higher
on the list than the general public but
they certainly don't fall into the
category
of the current asip recommendations or
what's happening
uh in texas or florida and many other
states um young healthy teachers should
be at no more risk
than young healthy individuals in any
other profession
so i would imagine that those and they
are critical infrastructure we love our
teachers
that they're going to be higher than the
general public but they're certainly not
going to be in in the next level
on almost any state because they're not
at higher risk
unless they are at higher risk if they
have hypertension or sickle cell disease
or a cancer survivor or over 65 of
course they go in that category but
otherwise
they're probably going to be further
down the priority scale because we need
to take care of those who are vulnerable
who will die who will be hospitalized
first and i think you're you're seeing
that both by the asip recommendations
as well as by several states it feels
like we're waiting for the point when
the united states gets to hurt immunity
what's your current estimate
so herd immunity when we get to herd
immunity
that is when the pandemic is essentially
over now there could be pockets in
certain places where their
vaccine hesitancy and people don't get
vaccinated
the truth is nobody knows exactly the
number but based on
mathematical models as we have it right
now it is somewhere between 70 and 80
of individuals having gotten the vaccine
or having gotten a natural infection
now obviously we want to develop herd
immunity by people getting the vaccine
because they're at no risk of ill health
effects or spreading it to other
individuals
somewhere in that 70 to 80 percent range
is probably the sweet spot
nobody knows for sure but based on
mathematical models
people kind of converge at that number
admiral we're running out of time but
final question
when do you expect that any american who
wants a vaccine
should be able to get the vaccine
well we are clearly on schedule 20
million
vaccinations distributed uh by the first
week in january we expect another 30
million in january another 50 million
in february and with the current
contracts even with just the vaccines we
have right now
we still expect that any american who
wants a vaccine can be vaccinated by
june
that's really very exciting that means a
couple hundred million people
being able to be vaccinated by that time
so um
with good mitigation steps with
increasing vaccinations particularly
among the those who are vulnerable
we should see clearly light at the end
of the tunnel
but we've got to keep discipline got to
keep vigilant right now as we vaccinate
admiral thank you for joining us thanks
for your service we wish you a happy and
very healthy new year